that code must be the most impractical
piece of archeology gear that I've seen
but you know it looks good my name is
Mariana Castro I'm an archaeologist at
New York University and today we're
going to be looking at our key ology
adventure scenes to see how real they
are we all try to dress like Indiana
Jones but nobody looks that good
[Music]
booby-traps don't tend to be very common
archaeological finds there's this
misconception that in the pyramids there
were a lot of booby traps but not really
so yeah the suspense is real we do make
that face when we find something really
really special why does he have a bag of
sand
[Music]
well archaeology is the study of things
of what people left behind and those
things only have meaning in a specific
context and if you remove the context
from an artifact as looters do and
that's really the problem you basically
lose a lot of the value of there that
artifact so if you can adjourns was a
real archeologist he would have stopped
and analyzed these booby traps because
honestly they're much more unique and
special than the idol okay just gonna be
very clear archaeologists do not carry
bull whips well just the fact of
throwing an Asian object like that I
mean let's start at the very basics
right oh my no don't tell any
conservator you did that
the whole part is kind of unbelievable
and I mean a system that is probably
thousands of years old is not going to
be working like that there were things
that were much more efficient in keeping
looters out for example curses writing
down curses on the film chamber or in
the the entrance of the tomb actually
was very effective in detracting people
from entering
you know what I wish my life was a
little bit more like this but it's not
unfortunately maybe two in this kind of
terrain with nothing more than sleds and
on foot imagine
mapping devices are heavily used in
archaeology you don't do anything
without a computer or GPS
assuming Ben's theory is correct and my
reconstructing the location of something
you would need to be able to program
that thing to incredibly specific
parameters the wind the currents the ice
breaks in this case it would be
impossible every time I see metal
detector it's kind of like this alarm
that goes in the head of every
archaeologist basically metal detectors
are not commonly used because you don't
want to constrain the results of the
excavation you don't want to focus on
just one thing normally you want to
layout your trench and you're going to
treat every piece of evidence equally
but you know that's the majority of
archaeological finds are not metal I
could just ship wind up we ain't here
well no expert but it could be that the
Hydra thermic properties of this region
produce hurricane-force ice storms that
cause the ocean to freeze and then
Melton refreeze resulting in a
semi-solid migrating landmass
meteorologists even have a hard time
predicting the weather for the week
so I'm not sure if you could predict
where the ship has been since it wrecked
three hundred years ago or however long
it was
[Music]
his methodology is definitely not
believable
we do use pickaxes a lot but we're not
that anxious to get to it I hope I don't
look like that when I'm pickaxe ink
we certainly did not find the best thing
of the whole excavation in the first 10
seconds that is very unlikely maybe you
get it in you know the last week if
you're lucky the way he gets to that
Bell is probably much more akin to how
looters excavate than archaeologists
[Music]
so it makes sense that this ship is well
preserved because it was found in ice
and kept in ice for hundreds of years
and ice is a stable environment for for
most materials I am going to give this
clip before
that code must be the most impractical
archaeology gear that I've seen but you
know it looks good
I just cherish there's no sora natural
they are actually speaking Russian it's
almost required for archaeologists to
know at least one language that is
relevant to their area studies
so the part of the computer braking was
the most accurate part of the clip so
far because he does happen all the time
I have never seen our killers just using
a glowstick headlamp a thousand times
more practical
[Music]
Betty was one of her tasks in the game
to ring the bell and then it explodes
yeah sounds very game-like nobody wanted
to be completely realistic that'd be
really boring
I would rape this one also too this is
an interesting example because a lot of
this initial footage was actually shot
at the original site it's a hundred
percent realistic because it's exactly
what they saw
depending on whatever circumstances you
find at the bottom of the ocean in
Titanic in this case some things can
preserve very well and some things can
disappear depends on oxygen light
conditions currents to make you turn
what's the law it wouldn't be the most
ridiculous thing to imagine that the
piano for example which is made of wood
and maybe ivory I don't know preserved
especially under you know it's a very
short time since it sunk a lot of the
expedition's that archaeologists are
involved in are funded by private
individuals and there's nothing wrong
with that
the the problem starts if the private
individuals want to keep the things that
you are researching you need to return
whatever excavate to the country of
origin we don't get to keep anything
ever
that's a really it's probably the most
common question that I get yeah you get
to keep any gold no we don't get any
monetary benefits that is proportional
to the things that we find I would rate
this clip in particular based on all the
documentary evidence that is included in
the movie eight
15:20 I don't see why a teenager would
be able to identify a lost object that
cross is an important artifact it
belongs in a museum these very cinematic
experience of us versus them and one
side is the archeologist and the other
side is the the bad looter makes sense
in in cinematic terms but in reality it
is not the archaeologists job to go
after the looters just from for the sake
of appearances putting things in your
pocket it's probably also one of those
101 archaeology lessons don't put things
in your pocket it's not our job to be
vindictive against looters so that's the
job of the law
the idea of what you do in the field and
how you sensitize people in your working
to what you're doing I think people
understand that that's their heritage
it's their responsibility to also
protect it so your role as an
archeologist is a lot more soft
diplomacy in that sense than it is
actually going after looters with guns
although I should say it was still
extremely inspiring for a lot of people
he has inspired a whole generation of
archaeologists so I would probably rate
this clip 1.5 because it's even less
likely that a child would do something
like this
an Egyptian sarcophagus with 700 years
that sounds very strange the King meets
the people at the Museum dirt get your
butt up here someone could scrape some
of the crap off this thing I think five
hours is the time that it would take to
get the sarcophagus to land and I think
there probably is the whole trip and
packing the sarcophagus from the ship
would take five hours because look at
the size of that thing
it would never get to the museum in five
hours that would never happen as we saw
when he was coming out of the ocean it
was full of in crustaceans of shells and
little animals from the bottom of the
ocean algae that takes again so you
don't damage the object it takes a long
time to remove them you don't just
scrape away on the spot this ladies and
gentlemen is what we do I don't know did
they wax the thing because obviously
five hours it wouldn't look like this at
all unless it's a fake that they
replaced it there's a whole conservation
process that you need to go through
before even displaying it in a museum
it would just be completely unrealistic
it takes months to diselenide things
that come from the bottom of the ocean I
would probably rate this clip at three
and this is an actual excavation for
sure there's this doesn't seem like a
sit this doesn't seem like I said at all
you can see that there are digging
trenches and everything is done in a
confined square or dig profiles where
you can have a very straight wall that
shows you the stratigraphy the layering
of your trench because what you just dug
out is equal to what you see on your
walls and then you draw that out and you
can assign artifacts that you found in
those layers and you can date them
whatever is above probably came after
what's underneath
basically stratigraphy is just a way of
dating your your trench and the material
that comes from it what comes later what
comes before that is a sieve and what
they're doing is probably just dumping
the earth that they're excavating in the
sieve sieving the things and sorting out
what was in that bucket that's a lot of
things for one bucket but it is possible
they're able to say that it's not from
the same period because that's a coin or
a medallion archeologists that are
really good at what they do they're able
to see something and see this is out of
place this doesn't belong in this period
even the little demon caked in in earth
was really nice touch because that's
exactly how they come out of the Earth's
actually dogs fighting is is a big part
of what I see when I'm on digs
[Music]
if we take the part where he's having
this supernatural connection with the
gargoyle I would say because of that I
will give it a 9 out of 10
that would be my face too
where'd you find this these are Plateau
1928 Giza is the place where the
pyramids the famous Giza pyramids are
located
I find never seen anything like this
you're having me neither
now there's there's two lines of
hieroglyphs the inner track has the
classic figures but the outer track is
like the cartouche in the center it's
got writing unlike we've ever found
before a common comment in our field
Stargate we don't study aliens we just
assume that people built the things
we're excavating it's very problematic
when you start to assign wonders of
humanity to an external source of power
credit where credit is due
why is the military so interested in
5,000 year old Egyptian tablets my
report says 10,000 not uncommon for
archaeologists in the military to work
together
the main reason normally is that the
archaeological site you want to excavate
is in a military site or a military
protected area in in these situations
whatever you do requires the permission
of the military so in a way they are
above you they're not the only ones
normally you also have the Department of
Antiquities or of whatever country
you're excavating in this figure 10,000
is ludicrous I mean the Egyptian culture
didn't even exist no
with the sonic and radiocarbon world
I mean radiocarbon is a thing and very
important for archaeologists today
things organic materials but I have no
idea what sonic dating is hiring an
archaeologist when you do have an issue
understanding something from the past
and maybe the secret military
involvement but I can't comment on that
because it's secretive I'm gonna give it
a four be underneath the thing you want
to open that's just the the recipe for a
disaster
I would not be playing golf in a nation
to Egyptian city any time in archaeology
there's an enclosed space you have to
wear those construction hats
oh my god is it this this looks like
some sort of a lock you can see here
several types of methodologies you can
use the brush you can use the hand you
can blow if it's something this
important you would probably go really
really slow because there could be paint
on it for example so first of all these
things are unbelievably heavy so not
sure how they transported them as
archaeologists you very rarely treat or
open or try to crack things inside
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not a ninja pathologist but from
what I've seen wouldn't just be one
layer of protection of the mummified
bodies inside a stone coffin you would
have a wooden coffin I am going to rate
this clip at two
[Music]
after you're all the work you put in
physically and mentally and all the
crazy research that you've done and then
you finally get to the site and you
discover something that is that means
something to you this is actually a
really good illustration of that feeling
that sense of wonder because it's a real
connection with the past okay this is my
dream I grew up with this movie so in a
way I always kind of imagined that
archeology at least would feel like this
big discovery and sometimes it does it's
beautiful I know I gotta hand it to you
really came through it's not one of the
most popular Disney movies but a lot of
people that went into archeology that
I've met also referenced this movie as
one of their starting points because
it's a cartoons appropriate for children
it taps into this imaginary this
wonderful thing that is to study the
past based on how realistic this clip is
in capturing the feeling of what it
means to be an archaeologist and those
light bulb moments I'm gonna give it a
10
you